okay so with this presentation we're
gonna go over some of the basics of
modern taxonomy the other day I
introduced some of the history of
classification the history of taxonomy
but let's look at what what we've
learned over the past couple hundred
years since taxonomy was created so if
you recall taxonomy was created by
carolus linnaeus and what taxonomy is
just to refresh our memory it's the it's
the branch of biology where life is
grouped life is classified according to
their shared traits and during the time
of Linnaeus he really only had physical
features to depend upon he would look at
the physical features of various animals
the physical features of various plants
and not just him but other scientists of
his time and they classified life
according to their features and so then
during the time of Linnaeus dolphins and
sharks were both classified as fished
when when you look at them they look
very physically similar well nowadays we
have more information nowadays we know
that mammals that dolphins are mammals
and that fish and that sharks are fish
mammals the Dolphins mammals have lungs
and sharks which our fish have gills and
that's not the only difference but
there's many we've learned that there's
a there's a lot more ways to interpret
classification besides just physical
features
and so how was life classified today
well we still do use physical features
and we have a fancy vocabulary word for
study in the physical features and
studying the form and studying the
structure and that's the word morphology
so yes we still do examine the
morphology examine the physical traits
the structure of organisms we also can
get gather information from the fossil
record the fossil on the right as I
believe it bats and the fossil on the
left is a spider and you'll see the
spider fossil again a little bit later
we also classify life today and this has
been some of the biggest breakthroughs
in this area right here has led to some
of the biggest breakthroughs in our
understanding of taxonomy zwi use
biochemistry to classify life we use
comparing DNA and RNA and amino acids
and chromosomes and proteins we'll talk
more about that in a moment
and we also study we also can use the
study of embryology the study of embryos
to see how embryos develop to kind of
give us a sense of how to group life
according to their shared traits but the
big thing I want to mention is that no
longer are we solely dependent and the
physical traits to classify life so when
we look at the area known as morphology
examining the form examining the
structure of organisms today is still
very important as was it during the time
of Linnaeus well one of the things that
we can look at is we can examine
homologous structures now this diagram
is something that we saw during the
evolution chapter but if you recall what
homologous structures are they are body
parts that have a similar structure yet
a different function so you look at the
four limbs of the of the human the cat
the whale and the bat they all provide a
different function the bats function of
its four limb is for flight a whales
function is for swimming cat for walking
human kind of have a multi-purpose arm
for grasping but they're built very
similar
to one another our form the human form
and the human structure is very similar
to a cat very similar to a whale very
similar to a bat and so what have we
learned over the years well we've
learned that if organisms have a similar
structure if organisms have a similar
form if organisms have a similar
morphology then they're closely related
when you look at these three pictures
here you may not think that whales bats
and elephants have very much in common
but when you examine their morphology
you can actually see that we have a lot
that these three animals have a lot in
common with one another for instance
their their morphology shows that they
all have all three of these whales bats
elephants have body here all three of
these give live birth to young they
don't lay eggs they give live birth all
three of these are warm-blooded so they
rely on their they are able to produce
their own body heat and they're able to
maintain their own body temperature all
three of these species right here the
whale the bat and the elephant they all
produce milk the females produce milk to
feed their young so due to the similar
morphology of these three animals all of
them are classified as mammals there was
a time where these animals probably
would have been looked at very
differently
I mean whales look like very big fish
and so at it there was a time when we
when we were still early in our
understanding of morphology where we
probably would have classified as
classified these three species as
something very different but today
because we learned more and we know how
to study the form and structure much in
much more detail we see that they have a
lot in common
well we also look at the fossil record
to help determine how to classify life
remember what the fossil record is it's
the collection of known fossils and when
we study fossils we can see similarities
and we can see differences when we
compare those fossils to creatures that
are still living today here we have a
tarantula father a spider fossil on the
left not sure if the fossil is of a
tarantula but we have a fossil of a
spider on the left and we have a
tarantula on the right so when we
compare fossils to creatures that are
still living today you can see
similarities you can see differences of
course there is a problem when it comes
to the fossil record the fossil record
is often incomplete here's a picture of
the fossil called Lucy very famous well
known early human ancestor fossil well
you notice how there's many bones that
are missing so it's very rare to
discover a full complete skeleton and
also it's just hard to find fossils some
organisms don't fossilize well soft body
parts don't leave fossils so it's hard
to find fossils of maybe jellyfish or
something that's a very soft organism
also just keep in mind that when
organisms die not off very often they're
dead remains are fed upon by scavenging
animals and so when an animal dies a leg
might get ripped off the dead carcass
and dragged somewhere else an arm might
get ripped off and dragged away
somewhere else so finding fossils intact
they're very hard fossils can be
disturbed by earthquakes the remains
that are found might be incomplete so
there are gaps in the fossil record but
with more time we are finding ways to
fill more of these gaps and so what have
we learned by studying the fossil record
well we learned today we've learned that
life today is related to life from ages
ago humans we're in a category of
organisms called primates and that goes
back millions of years - you can see in
the diagram - other primates that we
have relationships with and we'll talk
more about
I will talk more about about ways in
which we can use this information to
build upon our knowledge of
classification
one of the biggest areas of biology that
has helped us better understand
classification and taxonomy is
biochemistry in biochemistry what we're
learning to do is we're learning to
compare the DNA chromosomes RNA amino
acids proteins were learning to compare
the chemistry of living organisms and
we're learning to see how we can
determine who's more closely related
based on our DNA our amino acids our
chromosomes so similarities and
difference can be found we can look at
the similarities of human DNA and
chimpanzee DNA for example and we can
identify differences
we've seen this table earlier in the
school year if you recall this table
compares the differences between human
cytochrome C to nine other species
cytochrome C is a protein and like all
proteins it's made from a collection of
amino acids starting at the bottom human
and yeast cytochrome C has 42
differences as we move our way up human
and wheat germ cytochrome C has 37
differences human and fruit fly
cytochrome C has 24 human and bullfrog
we have 20 differences human and a
pigeon 12 differences in our cytochrome
C - there's humans and a cow ten
differences humans and a rabbit nine
differences humans and a rhesus monkey
one difference and then finally humans
in a chimpanzee when we compare our
cytochrome C to chimpanzee cytochrome C
they're identical so when you look at
this information it's a very strong
conclusion that humans and chimpanzees
are very closely related we have very
similar biochemistry and you can see it
in the amino acid sequence of this
particular protein
one thing we've also learned by studying
biochemistry is that DNA mutates DNA
changes every time organisms reproduce
when cells are copied every now and then
accidents are created we call these
accidents mutations and as time passes
as there's more as more time passes
there's more opportunity for DNA
mutations to occur so watch this picture
here here we have a common ancestor and
there's a small piece of DNA 25 million
years later you might have two separate
species and their DNA has little
differences and as time
I as time goes by as another 25 million
years go by so 50 million years total we
now have more differences so DNA mutates
at a known rate in when we look at the
DNA we can kind of have a good estimate
when did when did two organisms have a
common ancestor if we compare how
different their DNA is we can kind of
have a pretty good estimate for when
they had a common ancestor and so what
have we learned we've learned organisms
with similar DNA have a more recent
ancestor in this table it shows the
amino acids that make up only a very
small portion of the hemoglobin protein
hemoglobin is a protein and like other
proteins made from a collection of amino
acids and when you look at this table
you can see that the human and the
chimpanzee portion of this human globin
protein are identical there they're the
same so when we look at biochemistry we
can get an idea of which organisms have
similarities which organisms have a more
recent ancestor
okay so check out these four pictures we
have a human represented by Brad Pitt we
have an orangutan we have a gorilla and
a pygmy chimp and a couple pygmy
chimpanzees well what we've also been
able to examine and this relates to
biochemistry we've been able to examine
the chromosomes of all four watch this
picture this picture shows from left to
right a human chromosome and far-left
matched next to an orangutan and then
the next one a gorilla and then the next
one a pygmy chimpanzee and so when you
pick a chromosome number any chromosome
number look at chromosome 20 Roman
numeral 20 two x's on the bottom there
when you look at chromosome 20 the
chromosome on the left is he a human
chromosome 20 the next one over is an
orangutan number 20 the next one over is
a gorilla number 20 the next one over a
pygmy chimpanzee number 20 and when you
would line up chromosomes like this you
really do get a nice comparison of how
similar we are on the biochemistry level
with orangutans and gorillas and chimps
not only do we have the same number we
also have the same size and the same
color banding and and I want to make a
little amendment to what I just said
about the same chromosome number that
that's not entirely true humans we have
46 chromosomes and the great apes have
48 and if you if you've ever studied why
that is we think that too early
sometime in our past two of our
chromosomes became fused together making
humans have 46 chromosomes and other
members of the great ape having 48
chromosomes so I do want to make that
distinction there
so another area where we you where we
gather information to help classify life
isn't an area called embryology in an
embryology like the name implies ology
means the study of an embryo is the
study of how embryology is the study of
how embryos develop well here's a
picture of an embryo very early in
development very small very early in
development so early in development
there's a small group of cells known as
a blastula and in this forms again very
early in development well notice at the
bottom of the picture there's a small
little indentation there's a small
little opening we call that small little
opening we call that a blastopore you
know the word pore like you think of
pores in your skin they're tiny little
openings in your skin so that small
opening right there is called a blast
apart and what we can do is we can study
how do different embryos of different
species develop what's kind of funny and
interesting at the same time is the
blastopore will develop into the mouth
of some animals and eval develop into
the anus of others so comparing well
whose blast of horror turns into a mouth
and whose blastopore turns into an anus
we can kind of see who's related to one
another and so that little opening right
there will be the mouth of some animals
and the anus of others and what we've
learned is that if organisms develop
along a similar path that's a pretty
strong indication that they have a
relationship well what about humans what
does our blastopore turn into does it
turn into an anus or does it turn into a
mouth I know you've been dying to know
the answer to that question
here we go another picture of Brad Pitt
our starfish more related to humans on
the right or insects like the cockroach
on the left well one thing that we've
learned by studying the embryos of
insects by studying the embryos of
starfish and by studying the embryos of
humans one thing we've learned is that
humans and starfish our most likely have
more have a more recent ancestor we have
more in common we have a closer
connection and the reason we think this
is we could want one of the reasons we
think this is because the blastopore of
a human in the blastopore of a starfish
it forms the anus but the blastopore of
a insect forms the mouth organisms whose
mouth form from the blastopore are
called protists tones and organisms
whose anus develops from the blast or
blastopore are called deuterostomes just
it's just kind of a silly comical way to
show how we can study embryo development
to determine who might be related to one
another
and so this brings us to to this new
this this area of taxonomy known as
phylogeny and phylogeny is where we
study the evolutionary history of a
species and the picture right here is a
tool that we call a cladogram and a
cladogram is used to show the order in
which we think of species evolved from
their ancestors so for instance in this
picture we think a hagfish evolved first
and then a perch and a salamander and
then a lizard then a pigeon that a mouse
than a chimp and we're gonna go over how
to read these cladograms but when we
when we start to discuss these
cladograms and how to read them one
thing I want to mention is well we use
the evidence from all those topics we
just discussed to build a cladogram we
use evidence from morphology from
biochemistry from fossils from
embryology we use evidence from all
these areas to try to trace the
evolutionary history of a species well
let's go over cladograms and show you
how to build them and how to read them
so before we get into a biology example
let's kind of do a silly one here's a
list of six cities from around the world
when you're building a cladogram start
with a very broad trait that all the
organisms have in common so for instance
here's six cities from all over the
world one very broad trait that they all
have in common is they're all cities of
Earth again very broad well then we're
going to start to look for some some
pretty broad differences that might
apply to some but not others and I'm
gonna make a little bracket here and I
when I look at these six cities I
noticed a pretty obvious pretty major
difference a fairly broad difference
between a couple cities versus the rest
so again I'm gonna try to think of a
characteristics that that's a little
less broad than they're all cities of
the earth and when I look at these six
cities one thing I noticed a very it's
still very broad but not as broad as a
city of the earth as I noticed that a
couple of these cities are in the
eastern hemisphere and a couple are on
the west and four of them are on the
western hemisphere so just to make
following these easier I'm gonna label
the four that are in the Western
Hemisphere and the two that are in the
eastern hemisphere so let's follow the
branch of the Western Hemisphere
we rio de janeiro dallas quebec in las
vegas so you look at those four cities
right there I'm gonna make another
bracket another branch and when I look
at those four cities Rio Dallas Quebec
in Las Vegas one city stands out from
the other three I again I'm gonna try to
come up with a characteristic that's a
little less broad than being in the
Western Hemisphere and I think a very
good example in this situation would be
the fact that one of these cities is in
South America and three of them are in
North America the three North American
ones are Dallas Quebec and Las Vegas one
city by itself is in South America and
that's Rio de Janeiro so now that Rio de
Janeiro has has reached its end branch
let's focus our attention to North
America Dallas Quebec and Las Vegas so
of those three cities I'm gonna have to
make another branch and then of those
three cities I'm gonna try to think of a
less broad something a little more
specific and when I look at those three
cities I can see once one of those
cities is very different than the other
two one of those cities is in Canada and
two of them are in the United States so
the two in the United States Dallas in
Las Vegas the one in Canada has reached
an end branch that's Quebec well now we
have to look at Dallas and Las Vegas so
now I'm gonna have another branch and
I'm gonna come up with a very specific
something very specific to Dallas
something very specific to Las Vegas
well let's look at the state in which
these cities are located Dallas is in
Texas and Las Vegas is in Nevada well
let's go back to the bottom of the
cladogram here the eastern hemisphere we
have Paris and Rome so just like the the
top half of the diagram I'm gonna make
another branch and I'm going to try to
come up with a specific something
specific to Paris something specific to
Rome so let's just look at the countries
where these cities are found France is
where you find Paris and Italy is where
you find Rome so when you look at this
cladogram we've created this this
diagram where we've outlined some of the
features of these six cities well let's
try to read it now
so here's a quick question I took away
all the other cities I want to only want
you to focus on Dallas and Quebec
according to this diagram what is Dallas
and Quebec have in common
pause the video if you wanted some time
to think about it I'm gonna go over the
answer in three two one
so when we look at the answers start at
the far left and what we're doing here
is I'm tracing and showing you the path
that Dallas and Quebec follow before
they split Dallas and Quebec are Earth's
cities they're in the Western Hemisphere
and they're both in North America but
that's the three that they have in
common once you get to North America
they split Quebec is on the Canada
branch Dallas is on the USA branch so
that's kind of just a silly example of a
cladogram let's look at a biology
example so again here's the notes that
we were taken and here's that same
biology example looking at this
cladogram if I were to ask you to list
the characteristics of a salamander so
I'm hoping if you can pause the video
you can answer this yourself I'm gonna
go over the answer in three two one
so starting at the bottom if I were to
list the characteristics of a salamander
I'd start with the jaws and then I'd go
up to the next branch which would be the
lungs and that's it because the
salamanders stop the salamander branch
goes to the left and the lizard the
pigeon the mouse and the chimpanzee move
to the right so those are the only two
traits right they're listed in this
diagram of a salamander same cladogram
but here's a different question what
does a mouse and what does a lizard have
in common
according to this cladogram pause the
video if you want some time to think
about it I'm gonna go over the answer in
three two one so they have jaws in
common they have lungs in common but
then they excuse me and they have claws
and her nails in common
but then they split the lizard splits
and goes one direction the mouse splits
and goes another direction so everything
before the split they share in common
okay so here's another cladogram and if
we were in class I would give you guys a
minute to discuss this with your
neighbor but here's a couple questions
and pause the video and try to answer
these two questions I'm gonna go over
the answers in three two one
so question number one what does an
amphibian and a crocodile have in common
we'll start at the bottom and what we
notice is that they each have vertebrae
they each have a bony skeleton they each
have four limbs but that's really gonna
be it because they then split and branch
and go separate directions and phibian
branches to the left the crocodile
branches to the right so everything
before the split they possess in common
well what about number two list the
traits of array finned fish start at the
bottom
the ray-finned fish has vertebrae it has
a bony skeleton and then the Wraiths end
fish splits from the rest of the animals
from the amphibians the primates the
rabbit rodents the crocodiles the
dinosaurs and birds so everything before
the split the reef and fish possesses
everything after it does not
so here is a similar cladogram to what
you just saw it's just a different
format you're going to often see
cladograms in two different formats let
me put them side-by-side one another
so here this picture shows both types of
both styles of cladograms even though
they look different they're exactly the
same these are the same planograms just
two different formats so what does an
amphibian and a rabbit have in common
pause the video I'm gonna go over the
answer in three two one
so starting at the bottom and n phibian
and a vertebrate in each cladogram have
vertebrae in common in each cladogram
they have a bony skeleton in each
cladogram they have four limbs but
that's where they split the amphibian
breaks away you can see it in the top
diagram and the infibulation see it in
the bottom diagram going back to the top
diagram you can see that the rabbits
breaks away to the to the opposite
direction and now look in the bottom
diagram you can see that the rabbit
again breaks away to the opposite dire
opposite direction so everything prior
to that breaking apart they have in
common
vertebrae boney skin and foreign limbs
so here's a just an example of a very
complex cladogram now when you look over
these traits unless you study unless you
study these anemones these corals you
don't you're not really probably even
gonna know what some of this information
is and and I don't know what all of this
means and but that doesn't really matter
you don't really need to know what
calcitic sclera rights are if you know
how to read a cladogram you can answer
this question right here how many of
these eight species have calcitic
scleroids you don't have to know what
calcitic sclera rates are to be able to
read this pause the video try to figure
out how many of those eight to have
calcite explore rights and I'm gonna go
over the answer in three two one
so here's the answer of those eight that
the seven that I just labeled have
calcitic scleroids
because you can see that branch labeled
calcitic sclera it's everything before
everything before that calcitic sclera
right branch does not have calcitic
scleroids but everything attached
afterwards does and you can see those
seven are attached try this one of those
eight species
how many of them have a common oh I
don't want to say this wrong Cohen came
pause the video I'm gonna go over the
answer in three two one
so of those eight I hope you identified
those five right there everything before
that characteristic they don't have so
there are three animals before that
characteristic of a common Cohen a kind
I'm probably pronouncing that wrong I
apologize but everything after the
appearance of that trait you can see
that there are five organisms that
appear connected to that common Co
Anaheim branch one more example
okay so here's the last example how many
of these eight species have eight fully
developed Mezen terry's you don't need
to know what a fully developed mesentery
is the pause the video I'm gonna go for
the answer in three two one
so of those eight I hope you can see
that those two have eight fully
developed theories you see the
appearance of the trait it's labeled on
that branch while everything after the
appearance of eight fully developed
Mezen terry's will have a trait and you
can see these two appear after the
appearance of that characteristic so
we've reached the end go ahead and pause
the video and try to answer some of this
these questions perhaps on a separate
sheet of paper and I'd be happy to check
your answers before class or after
school one day so go ahead and pause the
video and try to work these out good
luck